[Music]
it's not necessarily that you don't
believe that this is the truth
you don't even want to see the truth
when actor jesse smallat lied about
being attacked by racist maga
hat-wearing trump supporters columbia
university linguist john mcwhorter
actually interpreted as a sign that we
have come further on race
than we're often comfortable admitting
if it really was
1960 except the window dressing had
changed there could not be a rachel
dollazole
and there could never be a
serious-minded
intelligent brilliant performing person
like jesse smallet
who pulls something like this and comes
out of it thinking that he's been
wronged
we're doing better than we think only in
an american which matters of race are
not as
utterly irredeemable as we are often
told he wrote in the atlantic would
someone pretend to be tortured in this
way because playing a singer on
television
is not as glamorous as getting beaten up
by white guys the unwillingness of both
blacks and whites to acknowledge
progress
on racial equality is a long-running
theme for mcwhorter who in 2000
published losing the race
self-sabotage in black america which
argued that in most cases
racism is not an obstacle to people
being the best that they can be in an
influential 2015 essay mcwhorter argued
that anti-racism has become a new
secular religion in america complete
with clergy creed and
also even a conception of original sin
when is born marked by original sin he
writes
to be white is to be born with the stain
of unearned privilege
black people he continues will express
their grievances and whites will agree
that they are racist you cannot rebuild
your civilization with somebody else's
babies you've got to
on the right mcquarter observes there's
a growing sense of hostility on racial
issues
and according to gallup the percentage
of americans who agree that black white
relations are good
is at a 20-year low and for the first
time since the pollster has asked the
question
a majority of blacks rate race relations
as bad
i sat down with the 53 year old
mcwhorter the author or editor of 20
books to talk about his upbringing in a
mixed race part of philadelphia his
academic focus on creole language
and the unmistakable signs of racial
progress that an increasing number of
americans
seem unwilling to acknowledge
john mcwhorter thanks for talking thank
you for having me
what kind of damage does a hoax like
the jesse smallett case do to race
relations well
what's interesting about the jesse
smollett case is that here's somebody
who pretends that he's been attacked
by whites and when it becomes clear
that he's lying refuses to admit it
implying that there's some larger sense
in which he's correct and what he means
by that i'm not sure how clearly he
started out but
what he means by that is that he
represents a larger story
the problem with this is that he is
one making it so that some people will
be more skeptical about actual attacks
like that because there is racism in the
country
there is homophobia in the country but
then on the other hand
he's also participating in
something that we very peculiarly
especially as educated americans
consider to be some sort of higher
wisdom some sort of
duty which is to pretend that
racism in america not only exists but
is more prevalent than it is and what i
mean by prevalent
is not whether or not you can tease out
certain unsavory attitudes from people
under the artificial conditions of a
psychological experiment
but how much effect it has and so we're
taught to suppose that
if certain racist biases exist in the
hearts of certain people
then it's of this portentous import and
we're not supposed to ask what the
import is
now if somebody is going to get beat up
yes that's a very serious problem
but the thing is people walking down the
street and getting beaten up by white
racist thugs is thankfully something
quite rare in america today it's not
that it doesn't happen but it's
extremely rare and it didn't happen to
jesse smallett
but in terms of whether or not residual
racist feelings have a significant
effect upon the trajectory of black
lives whether black people are poor
middle class or above the truth is we
are
in a very new era and it's considered
the height
of enlightenment for both whites and
blacks to pretend
that that isn't true and that's the
problem that we have so
i mean and this is a long-running
long-running observation for you in 2001
an interview with reason um you said
that white racism was no longer the main
obstacle to black self-flourishing but
you know and i mean you just said
something similar how do you know that
or how do you prove that
um first and then second why don't we
want to acknowledge that i mean it seems
to
be like you know something we could
actually be proud of as a country and as
a society
sure there was a time when to be black
meant that you were effectively
shut out of dignified professions
you got your training as a lawyer and
you could not hope to be a prestigious
lawyer beyond the confines of the
so if you're black you were you might be
in a segregated community you got to be
the best lawyer there but but that's as
far as you were going to get
and then in terms of the social
territory
you were subject to regular open
expressions of bigotry that's just the
way it was
i think of that as what the generation
before me as somebody who was born in
1965
which means that i don't become really a
person until the early 70s
that's what the generation before me had
to go through and what was always clear
to me as i was growing up
was wow that's awful the way it was
recently and i was under no impression
that it had been only
you know black and white photographs of
people in funny clothes 100 years ago i
knew it had been you know my parents
and i thought well what happened in the
60s really was significant and it turned
life upside down
and i knew that my life was not
completely devoid of racist bias that
you encounter here and there but it
never
kept me from getting anything that i
wanted now i could say that as a very
middle-class boy
if i had grown up less fortunate then
okay i could see that especially
systemic racism
was responsible for me having a harder
time
doing certain things but even there
we're talking systemic
not official and not overt
and even the racist biases were ones
that weren't going to
determine that you couldn't do things
and that difference
seemed to me to be something to
celebrate i could have although not very
articulately have said that
at 11 i thought the civil rights
victories that i've been taught about by
my
very passionately pro-civil rights and
frankly not liking white people very
much
grew up in the deep south in the 40s
mother i knew what had happened in the
60s and i thought wow it worked
and as i came of age i realized that i
was not supposed to think that and so
how do i know there's
a very simple comparison that i often
use and i hate to say this
in some ways but it's necessary because
it works here in 2019
suppose you have a choice what do you
want to be do you want to be
a black person of any class
living in any neighborhood or do you
want to be a white person
who weighs 400 pounds choose now
in 1920 i think almost anybody would
choose to be william howard taft
even if he hadn't become president 400
pound white person
well you know life wouldn't be great you
know the dating market
things might be difficult i might you
know have some health issues but at
least
i would be white most people wouldn't
even have chosen
today no one no one would say
rather than being a black middle manager
who you know once or twice gets pulled
over by the cops for no reason and every
now and then has detected certain biases
i would rather be a white person who
weighs 400 pounds
or a white person who has really
terrible acne even that one
i think the choice is easy so what is
you know why don't we want to
acknowledge and when i say we i mean i
think
you're right that you know most people
in america for a variety of reasons
are uncomfortable saying you know we
we're we're doing a lot better now what
what
what is holding back people from
acknowledging progress
and not like some kind of utopian
perfection but but
significant progress it's a funny thing
that's happened and i wish that
intellectuals and academics were more
interested in studying it because it was
complex but it wasn't that complex but
we're taught not to see it
when it got to the point the conditions
for black people were profoundly
different
from the way they were the landscape
opened up in such a way that you could
have anti-racism
and the crucial aspect of anti-racism is
that part of it is pretending things are
worse than they are
and not being open to clear facts that
indicate progress
anti-racism can take a place as
a way of showing that you're a good
person that's the white
version and so there has been
anti-racism
you know since the dawn of time but
especially since the late 1960s you can
watch the norman lear sitcoms and the
character of maude reflected a certain
reality but something happened in this
country about five years ago
where being on the side of the angels
meant that you were supposed to
deny facts that you were supposed to
exaggerate that you were supposed to
embrace a notion such as that
whites are supposed to be guilty of a
privilege that they have upon
birth and the evil of it cannot be
expunged it all started sounding like
fundamental christianity and that
happened in about 2013.
okay so well let's get to that year in a
second and then what happened if
whites started saying okay well no i'm
really guilty and i understand that i'll
be quiet while you
speak what happened you know what what
form does it take among blacks
yeah the the black situation was older
and is only reinforced now
400 years of oppression 400 years of
being treated like an animal
let's say this is up through to the end
of jim crow
it can be hard to have a positive
self-image especially
if there's no single country to look
back to as where it all started so it's
not like being chinese or even irish
so you don't have a strong sense
of self of strength one way
that you can develop a substitute sense
of strength
after 1964 is to become the noble victim
and so if you're not sure that you're
good enough and it's completely
understandable why somebody would think
so
then one way to think of yourself as
good is to think
i am somebody who stands up under this
constant oppression and of course it
isn't like it used to be
it's in the air i can smell it i know
it's there and you can't tell me that
it's not there
so that noble victim complex is human i
mean i'm sure that there have been noble
victims since human beings were running
around in small bands
of hunter-gatherers but to be a black
person is to have that
as one way of feeling whole all sorts of
people have ways of feeling whole to be
a black person
is to have that one available and so i
think that these days we've taken our
place
in this religious structure where we
are the prophets we are the witnesses
the white person talks about how racist
they are and our job
is to acknowledge that they've said so
and to absolve them
that day of their sin and that gives us
a certain significance
is it is it absolution or is it like
actually
no you're even worse than you thought
because i mean it seems like that often
is the case it's like
don't apologize to me because you're
just saying you're just apologizing
you're actually
right even in saying that that's white
privilege you expect to be absolved of
sure racism that's a type i think that's
more common in academia and among
intellectuals
is this i mean what are the generational
dimensions of this because i i mean do
your parents say who
who lived in an era where racism was you
know much more ubiquitous much more
pervasive and pernicious do they feel
like
overall things are better or are they
part you know are they like no things
have always things just keep getting
worse it's funny you
you ask about my parents and it happens
that neither one of them
are alive and it's okay to ask about
them they were both
very complicated and idiosyncratic
people neither one of them were
archetypes
of any typical black story that we hear
but
my mother was one of the most brilliant
people i've ever known
i am her i talk like her i
teach like her but my mother was very
much
she was somebody who participated in
sit-ins and
she frankly had an indelible sense
of white people as deeply racist the
term white privilege was not used as
much at the time
but my mother was not gonna let go of
that
and i say with great love and respect
for her that
she thought of it as part of her mission
as a black person continuing what was
called in her day the struggle
to frame everything that she could
as being about systemic racism it's a
mission that a lot of people of her
generation who were intellectuals
developed
in the 60s and 70s and you know i know
already i'm 53
my views on big things are not likely to
change
i'm not going to let my views go it
would take massively contradictory
evidence
you freeze and my mother at my age had
hit that point
my father was a different kind of
individual and
it'd be interesting if either one of
them could hear me saying any of this
but
my father had a certain sense
of self-love
that was independent of larger events he
did not think of himself
as a downtrodden black person he grew up
part of the solid philadelphia working
class
and he had a lot of problems but he
liked himself
he would have agreed with
the crop of people these days like me
you know if he
lived now he would be patting me on the
back and saying that people needed to
hear the sorts of things that me
and glenn lowry and coleman hughes and
the rest say
he would have read he was alive but not
reading too much by then but he would
have read shelby steele's work
and nodded does it oh yeah i'm just the
list of people that you mentioned that
all male is there a gender dynamic to
this that
intersects with with racism i'm not sure
why it is that when you give a list like
that that year after year decade after
decade
the people who are most known for
expressing views like that
are men there are card carrying
conservative black women
countless numbers of them in the
ordinary population who people like me
and the others hear from
but in terms of the ones who you know
are on tv and
writing for magazines it's not as common
and nick to tell you the truth i do not
have
a glib answer why and i'm going to make
one up however i'm going to look this up
if there are generalizations to be made
about the nature
of men and women and there are some and
they're just probabilistic but of course
there are some
if women are more inclined to
network socially and to seek consensus
while men
are more likely to assert
by themselves and be lone wolves if
that's true
my sense having known all of the
conservatives as well as all the just
heterodox people like myself over the
past 20 years is that
all of us are kind of lone wolves
there's a reason that there's no one
organization there's a reason why
there's that one podcast where glenn
and thomas and camille and
coleman and i all get together that's
rare that all of us would be in the same
room it's kind of like we're all not us
individually but
it's like people who are black objectors
are kind of magnets and kind of
and so and i think it's because we're
all people who kind of generate our own
sense of self-worth sitting in a chair
drinking some bourbon and looking out
the window
that type maybe is less likely if you're
a woman
that's the only explanation i can think
of
so you mentioned the year 2013 where
that would put us still in the obama
years one of the explanations and again
when you look at survey data you know
and there's limits to the legitimacy of
it but
there's a real decline in in optimism
about race relations in america
many people theorize that it's obama
you know at a moment which is you know i
i
you know it's staggering right i mean
this is what a delivery on
a system that had [ __ ] up for uh you
know hundreds of years like
we elected a black man and that actually
there was a backlash and that that
made race relations more difficult do
you do you buy into that or does that
make sense or
then what was going on in 2013. yeah i
know that analysis is going to go down
in the books because it makes for good
theater but no
what happened was that obama was elected
in 2008
and in 2009 which is now 10 years ago
and it's
we have to work hard to remember what
life was like before 2009 is the first
year that when you were at a party
someone would say you're not on facebook
rather than
you know you're oh you're on facebook
that was the year that quote unquote
your mother was on facebook
2009 was also the year that twitter
really took off
to the point that for example my
students were telling me about it and i
was saying do i have to do this
that happened in 2009. so social media
as we describe it became part
of every minute of your life in 2009.
that just happened to be the case and so
obama is new
and that meant that something like the
tea party could really jump
in a way that it couldn't have before i
fully believe that if john edwards had
become president there'd be a tea party
too
but to the extent that obama's race had
anything to do with it and it did have
something to do with it now a lot of
people think if you say something what
you really are supposed to mean is 95
and i don't think that it had some to do
with it it was magnified by the fact
that
life was suddenly in your pocket and
that is also why
i sincerely believe it's an interesting
what-if kind of experiment
if there had been no social media until
say this year
and obama came in i think that america
would have turned a corner
on how it thought about race just
because of the sheer
driving presence of that family on tv
or on your phone every night but instead
what happened
was and this was good in some ways cop
killings of black men
became a national obsession because it
was in the phone
if amadou diallo had been in your phone
that would have been
the moment but instead it was in the
newspaper something you hold and then it
goes away
so trayvon martin that ends up in your
phone that becomes a cause white people
all over america are wearing hoodies
as soon as that started quieting down
mike brown and ferguson
and even though i think more and more of
us today can admit
that the story we were given about that
was not the case
it had a symbolic value and i think that
that taught white america
that race relations were worse than they
were and as a result
in 2013 we turned a new corner in how we
thought about race it was the beginning
of whites being woker than black people
and so you have trayvon martin in 2013
mike brown right after that what
happened to trayvon martin was horrible
what happened to mike brown was
unfortunate he was not shot with his
hands up but who
wishes that that had but he shouldn't
have been he he shouldn't have yet he
should not have died
and that happened and more people knew
about it and talked about it and worked
one another up about it than would have
even five years before
and from then on especially the issue of
the cops
and young black men came front and
center
the work of tahasi coates helped to
support that
ta-nehisi coates you know i wish him
well but we wouldn't be talking about
him
if it had not been for social media and
what happened in 2013-14
and as a result it has taught a whole
generation of white americans and not
just a generation but even older ones
that things are worse than they are and
or to pretend
that they're worse than they are as a
way of signaling your morality a
tribal feeling emerged and it was
because
of facebook and twitter which i would
not give up
for any amount of money but social
history has an element of randomness to
it
so you a couple months ago uh in the
atlantic you wrote about uh the culture
of hypersensitivity which is
certainly on campuses but it's in other
aspects it's in the media and whatnot
um with that is so what is driving that
is is social media is essentially what
you're saying oh yeah
i mean you and i nick can remember what
it was like to be
you know leftwardly inclined people in
college
and the response to
offensive matter was quite different
and a lot of the reason it was different
was because people simply couldn't stoke
one another up the way they can now
because of the phones in our pocket and
it's not an accident that
microaggression is something that i
remember reading about in some academic
papers
in the late aughts and it was something
that you only knew about
if you were of those circles it was in
2014 that my undergraduates
started talking about it and interesting
not 2012. in 2012 i'm sure i could have
heard a pin drop if i said
microaggression in the class
2014 they're telling me about it and
it's around then that you have this
clump
of campus protests about things which
left you wondering whether the concerns
really merited the tenor of the response
and to be honest if you went to college
even back in the 80s you knew about
these takeovers of president's offices
but the virtual epidemic
that there was in 15 and 16 was a direct
result of this new mood and what's
interesting
i don't hear people saying it yet and i
might be wrong that was a surge that is
passed
it was a fashion and i don't think it's
going to happen as much
now partly because of a certain pushback
among the chattering classes about it
but the reason that that started
happening across the country in so many
schools for a few years in the middle of
the teens
was a result of this new social media
driven hyper sensitivity to issues of
race which also created
a religious sense of prayer about race
over activism
there's a right-wing version of that too
i mean like you know trump supporters
are hypersensitive as well
so it i mean i think it cuts both ways
and then kind of feeds on itself
you know what i hate to say though that
um i
despise the president and
my feeling is that anyone who voted for
him has a different
prioritizing of concerns than i do i
don't think that anybody who voted for
donald trump
is social detritus i don't think anybody
who voted for donald trump is a racist
but
it is a choice that i have a very hard
time imagining making
and if anybody has voted for him i often
think
their priorities are different from mine
in ways that i kind of
regret nevertheless i think that an
awful lot
of that racial response
among the people whose vote for trump
was informed partly by race
is not just an outgrowth of the feeling
that white people had about black people
when d.w
griffith was making his films it's
partly
a kind of person who's tired of being
told that they're a racist
on the basis of a definition of racism
that's so abstract that it's difficult
to actually
adopt a sense of blame about it so we're
taught as educated people that racism is
something
so abstract it's racism
if boys in chicago black boys are
shooting each other
over sneakers every summer that's racism
because they feel that america doesn't
like them no that doesn't quite work
that's racism because their father went
to jail
because of drug policies that were
focused on both hippies
and black people in 1969 you know all
these things might make a certain formal
sense
but the white person who's running a
liquor store in bethlehem pennsylvania
and they're not making it work and
they're worried about their job and
they're being called a racist because
of this sentiment or that sentiment
they're tired of that
and i hate to admit i wouldn't hang out
with that person from bethlehem
pennsylvania who's running the liquor
store
and is tired of the blacks but still
some of their feeling is defensive
rather than
offensive and that's not to say that i
think racism is a good thing
that's not to say that i wish they
couldn't be more educated about the fact
that racism is not
just burning across on somebody's lawn
you know archie bunker needs some
teaching
but there's an extent to which a lot of
these people i sound like glenn lowry
but glenn is right on this
a lot of these people are tired of being
called what they feel as a dirty name
and a lot of people on the left feel
that they need to learn to understand
why it's appropriate to call them that
let's wait to see whether that could
ever happen uh you mentioned uh glenn
lowery and you uh
do various kinds of talking blogging
head video
uh discussions with him in a recent one
you guys were talking about
um or maybe i should say you people were
talking about reparations
uh and this is a kind of interesting
notion which tony heasy coats
helped to reinvigorate a discussion of
going back to an earlier debate by
randall kennedy
in your dialogue with glenn you
pooh-poohed the idea of reparations
is are reparations a bad idea because
it's not politically
viable or because it's a bad idea oh no
no reparations are
a great idea we had them so anybody who
says we need reparations for slavery is
pretending that there was no affirmative
action
or that there was no community
reinvestment act of 1977
and you know i could go on and on and on
and so the question just becomes
is it that you think that those things
didn't work and there need to be new
reparations that would in which case the
question becomes what do you think would
work
and in this whole debate is considered
somehow beside the point
to make people specify what do you think
would work what new policies would work
okay you're going to put money into
certain organizations
in order that they do what and to the
extent that it's considered kind of
spoiling the party to ask those
questions it reveals that what we're
talking about is religion
it's scriptural to say what we need is
reparations it's a variation on saying
that
america needs to come to terms with race
without specifying what the terms are
or even what you're talking about what
terms
what event what human interaction are we
referring to
you're not supposed to ask any more than
you're supposed to ask about judgment
day or the rapture
this is genuinely a religion now the new
idea about reparations
is what one idea always has been but the
one that i sense people are focusing on
now
is that you put money into the bank
accounts
of anybody who is black to make up for
the wealth
that was denied their ancestors now
besides the
ethical problems with that that glenn
lowry has identified
the question has to become this wealth
goes into people's accounts and let's
say that that happens
and so there have been reparations and
there's a ceremony and somebody cuts a
ribbon
and you know there's some you know this
this festival and mary j blige sings and
you know ex-president obama comes and
makes a speech and then he sings amazing
grace again
and it's happened and everybody gets up
and mitch mcconnell even says
i'm sorry after that happened
i wonder and this is something i could
get along with the idea that that would
happen
if the black intelligentsia and
black political leaders and black
community activists could say
after that happened okay we admit
that we have really turned a corner now
that doesn't mean that they have to say
that nothing else ever needs to happen
but they would have to say wow we have
overcome
now we've got some sweeping up to do but
whitey
is no longer on the hook and nick my
problem is that i don't think those
people would say that
i think that the whole call for
reparations is really based on emotion
it's based on a sense of identity it's
based on a sense of
needing a psychological crutch because
of the whole that jim crow and slavery
and redlining left
in our souls and so i think that after
the reparations happen
everybody would just be saying the usual
people the people with three names as i
like to say on blogging heads
would say okay reparations was just the
beginning upon which i'd be thinking
given that there already were
reparations before
now there are these new ones and you're
not happy or the smart take would
instantly be
i think it's problematic for them to
assume that they can just write
a check and have it all be over and
everybody would snap their fingers
well if that's the way it's going to be
why do it
and so i could get on board i'm saying
this officially i could get on board
with pumping this money
into black people's accounts i'd get
some i frankly wouldn't mind getting
50 000 for nothing because i'm black
okay that's not going to hurt anybody
but only if black america's leaders
could let that matter
and i don't think they could is there
you know as you're talking about black
identity and black leaders and whatnot
one of the odd things if going back to
the say the mid 90s the
census bureau started allowing for
designating yourself as other or as
multi-ethnic
people like tiger woods uh my colleague
matt welch and i wrote a book
uh in one chapter where we were using uh
tiger woods as
as you know the avatar of a new
multi-dimensional mass
customized in hyper-individualized
america he called himself a kabbalah
nation because he was caucasian black
american indian and and south asian
indian
um and we seem to be getting into more
you know rather than har you know
broader more hard
harshly defined categories everybody was
kind of
we were on a gradient we were on a
spectrum is any of that happening now
because when you look at the society
we are more multi-ethnic there's more
inter-marriage there's more
foreign people coming here who hadn't
been here before in mixing and all of
this
but the identities seem to be getting
shrinking the number of
identities seem to be shrinking even as
a social reality is this
proliferation of types it's a religion
and so
it's considered advanced to say well
okay that person may have only one
eighth
black blood in them but if they think of
themselves as white
or if they don't think of themselves as
black they're in denial
they don't like us they don't understand
the realities
and of course all of that sounds like
jefferson davis
it's the one drop rule and if someone
says if someone like thomas chatterson
williams says why are we applying the
one drop rule ourselves
well that's considered conservative
thought
you know are we supposed to conserve the
views of jefferson davis
and the idea is that you're supposed to
let
something that doesn't make sense pass
out of a quest to constantly assail
white america for being racist and yeah
it's getting
really really delicate i mean it's at
the point where
for example and it's interesting with my
daughters go
online and watch this in 20 years my
wife is white
and my daughters are you know in between
my color
and her color one of them is closer to
mine one of them is closer to hers
both of them you might think so you're
running a natural experiment there
yes and one of them you'd probably think
she was mexican
the other one you can kind of tell she's
what used to be called mulatto
however they're also growing up upper
middle class in 2019
culturally they're growing up quote
unquote white i give them some of
my black things but they're they're
they're white girls what what is a black
thing
a black thing is in shallow things like
cuisine
shallow things such as making sure that
they hear a certain kind of music
and by that i don't mean hip-hop but
they're going to have their stevie
wonder in them
they're going to listen to their bessie
smith they're going to have a certain
sense of rhythm that you have to have by
having certain music around you at all
times and i want them to
have certain views of dialect that you
have if you grow up listening to people
speaking in different ways
but a lot of that is superficial they're
going to grow up to be just people
now if it were 1975 there'd be no
question as to whether they were white
or black you said they were black
because they were going to be treated as
black no matter what and that was true
but here in these times that's not true
anymore because there's so many
mutts and so we there's so many biracial
and multiracial people
there's some people i've talked to where
and i don't ever let it get very far i'm
getting old and cynical enough that i
know when to cut the conversation off
very carefully by turning around
but i've said are my daughters black
i'm not sure and of course some people
are thinking well he just doesn't want
them to be black he thinks he wants them
to be white
as if i'm some self-hating person from
1935 i don't hate myself i would
frankly rather be this color but i just
say is it meaningful to say that they're
african-american i'm not seeing it i
think that they are not
white they're just mutts and i've had
some people tell me
white people you can't know what kind of
racism they're going to experience
upon which i just let it go but my
answer inside
is yeah now and then but not nearly
enough to define a life not nearly
enough to in
any coherent sense define an identity
but to tell you the truth in
conversations like that i know that no
matter how i said it
i will be regarded as heretic
that's the climate well that but that's
you know
uh you're talking a lot about a new
religion and it's kind of fun to be the
heretic then right
no it's no no you don't think john of
arc was laughing it up on the
buyer there you know you mentioned
language and dialect and whatnot and a
lot of your academic work is
is in creole languages pigeons and
things like that
you are a remarkably relaxed linguist i
think most of us when we think of
linguists we're like uh
you know i'm afraid to say am i using
who or whom correctly all of this
explain your approach to language
because it's it's really kind of a
fascination about the way that language
is constantly evolving and that it's
a means to an end and you seem to be
very
against the idea of insisting on certain
linguistic
etiquette as a marker of intelligence or
class or anything like that
yeah um that language being race me
don't intersect much it's you know
creaky gears shift
in my head but if you're a linguist and
if you happen to be especially the kind
of linguist who
has a surface familiarity with hundreds
of different ways of being a language
around the world
you can't help but realize that any
notion
that putting it in this way rather than
that way
is wrong or unscientific or incoherent
or not clear
just doesn't make logical sense then the
intersection the tiny
you know piece of flesh between chang
and n bunker intersection
is that um you know contrary to what
some people think i am black
and i grew up listening to a very
different dialect of english
people who were close to me who i loved
and liked
are speaking in this way that made
perfect sense to me
so the idea that black english was bad
grammar
never made any kind of intuitive sense
to me at all
and so with those two things it means
that if somebody says less books instead
of fewer books to me the idea that
that's wrong
doesn't work because languages work in
seven thousand different ways
because black people make as much sense
as white people and often more
and three i'm a historical linguist
which means that my specialty is to know
about what language was like before
and so i know that the whole idea of
fewer books being better
than less books has nothing to do with
the way english has been
since it was a language called
proto-germanic then old english and
middle english
none of this makes sense so yeah a lot
of people think because i have a starchy
demeanor
etc and because i'm supposedly a
right-wing conservative that when it
comes to language
i'm going to be very winston churchill
no not at all and that's not
a pose i'm not a libertine kind of
person it's just simple
linguistic logic um
what are your politics how do you define
yourself politically i am a
cranky liberal democrat
frankly if it were 1960 and people were
drinking their cocktails nobody
would have any sense of me being in
you know me being a conservative of any
kind it's
our sense of race and this happened long
before 2013.
our sense of what's normal about race
went way left
in about 1966 so that if i say something
like
affirmative action should be based on
socioeconomics
that meant basically all black people in
1966
but by 1986 that needed to really stop
being only about black people that's not
a conservative position
it only seemed that way because of this
sort of stokely carmichael sense of
where race is supposed to sit
and so a lot of people think that it's
funny back in the arts
i remember yeah i'm going to say it when
the root
the publication the root started they
called on my services
and they called on me thinking of me as
you know they want to seek balance and
i'm i'm conservative
and it was the oddest thing i found that
the writers at the root
actually thought that i was going to
write columns in support of john mccain
they thought that i was supporting
mccain over barack obama who i thought
of as the shining black
beacon of political smarts they actually
thought that i preferred john mccain
the reason they thought that it's not
because they're bad people or sloppy
they hadn't done their homework
it's because they think that if a black
person says anything that say michael
eric dyson wouldn't agree with
then they must be a republican
conservative that's because of a strange
aspect of our race dialogue where race
has been hard left whereas liberalism
otherwise
has been quite rightward of that will
that ever change i
i one of my uh heroes i guess are a
figure that i go back to
on a fairly regular basis is jackie
robinson the baseball player who
wrote a fantastic oral history of
integrating baseball right before the
civil rights act and the
voting rights act in the mid 60s cold
baseball has done it
he campaigned for richard nixon in 1960
by the late 60s he was no longer doing
that but
he you know and i guess eisenhower
pulled
something in the 30s or 40s of the black
vote
at least in his first term is that at
all possible or is
is the black political identity like so
tightly wedded to the democrats and
is that the democrats fault or is it is
it the democrats attracting them
or the republicans were pulsing them
it's going to change
and i think that social media is going
to help with that
yeah you see somebody like jackie
robinson and you can't call him crazy
and yet his politics often didn't work
in terms of what we expect of them
now and you look at those those people
in black and white
and they suffered a racism that you know
most of us today will never know
and yet they came out you know voting
for richard nixon etc
and you know sometimes we'll say sammy
davis jr it's because they were
politically naive
but with other ones like jackie robinson
there was no naivete there it's just
that
he didn't feel that racism should
determine
everything about him the way we do now
and if you had asked me 10 years ago
whether this was going to change
i would have been pretty skeptical but
you know social media helps
and so it used to be that a shelby steel
would write a book
and boy was he lucky that so many people
read that book in 1991 but that was
unusual
and it was just a book and most human
beings don't read books
nowadays i think there is a critical
mass
of black people who are trying to think
about things
most of whom are not republicans and yes
i am talking about me as being one of
them
and instead of writing books that
nobody's going to read we're on social
media
where there are accessible venues where
we can
get our point across such as this one
where we're
just talking you know abc news wouldn't
have let me do this
20 years ago they they pretended they
were going to three times wasted my time
three times
but i'm evil as opposed to the other of
course they never said it but you know
tavis smiley gets his say but i'm just
wrong
that's less the case now you can't keep
me out of the media now the way you used
to be able to
and that's also true of people who are
genuinely on the hard right and black
and god bless them too
and so i think that we're getting to
people people like me and glenn lowry
noticed that
there are people out there who are
listening and so i would imagine it's
gonna take a while
you know a lot of the people who are
watching us are young and or in college
but
i think something's gonna change it
depends on what sorts of candidates are
put
forward but for example if the
republicans put forward somebody who is
not a [ __ ]
and who is clearly a person of substance
but rejects the kind of knee-jerk
condescending identity politics of
certain democratic politicians
yeah i think that that could happen it's
not going to happen in the next election
but start watching something different
may be happening in the one after that
depending on who's put forward but the
problem is that the republican party has
become such a gang
it's a cage of apes at this point and so
at this point the democrats maybe will
be all there is
give it 20 years and maybe things will
change you uh have been teaching now for
decades and you've taught at a wide
variety of schools yeah you're getting
old
okay yeah obviously you're dying your
hair but no
look at my eyebrows but do you think
universities
are getting better or worse in terms of
intellectual freedom
and courage yes it's bad
and you know it's not as is that not
just amongst students but among faculty
worse
you know the the polarization is worse
than it was when you and i went to
college
and none of this is over and it's not
that faculties are quote unquote tenured
radicals but the issue is
what you're going to cover in a class
for real what's going to be said
out loud what sorts of behavior from
students is going to be essentially
tolerated what sorts of programs are
going to be allowed to be instituted
versus which ones aren't
most of it is underboard it's kind of
like racism
and yeah i mean if you're an institution
that wants to keep up its endowment and
make as much money as it can in order
to continue you are going to be pious
where you need to be and that's going to
be the corporate understanding
and no one is going to stick their necks
out and so
certainly i see people who
feel one way as individuals but it's
understood that when they're in the
business suits
none of that can come out now that's not
to say that they're people who aren't
committed
to there being free speech
that's there and it goes differently
from campus to campus i can say i'm
lucky i can say
columbia hasn't had an outbreak of
student rage
in the way that many other campuses have
and i'm not sure we're completely sure
why
but there is also a strong at least
overt commitment
to free speech it hasn't been tested by
anybody you know on hamilton steps
screaming for any dean's heads
but still there is a commitment to
getting past
this kind of gridlock but in general no
academia
it's funny talk about me getting old
part of the way that i'm getting old is
that i've been doing
the race thing now for basically 20
years i started in the year 2
2000 1999 depending on how you count it
and one thing i've seen
is that in terms of who hates me
in terms of where i get the most
decisive snubs
it's academia it's not so much the
general public i have my haters out
there and i hear from them sometimes but
it's nothing like it was 10 years ago
especially since i've never put out the
stridently right-wing message that many
people used to accuse me of
the inveterate of
heated despising of me is among people
with phds
and i think a lot of them would suppose
that they're correct because they have
phds but i'm sorry
the fields themselves are such that
there's such a narrowing of what they
analyze and how they interpret data that
i disagree that i've done anything to
deserve that judgment
and that's a problem but academia is not
the world
and so the truth is that the world's
views maybe
are going to be more labile than those
of our most scholarly classes and that's
just the way i think it's going to be
frankly i don't see that changing
anytime soon
well on that note we will leave it there
thank you so much john mcwhorter
we've been talking to john mcboarder
he's a linguist at columbia has written
a
shelf full of books and he's got a lot
of opinions and find him at the atlantic
on a regular basis and all over the area
john thanks so much
thank you
[Music]